I've been to the mountaintop and it
feels like to win and win with some of
your best friends that's why I be hard
to believe just because I put so much
blood sweat tears in this building I've
had my ups and downs but I could've
imagined myself being somewhere else
with time things change so it's hard for
me a vision what goes on at night Mars
he's awarded and obviously that's no
other way to describe him please want to
give everything you got every time we
step on the floor he could be a part of
a team and win championships he'll be a
legend he'll have to impact me on
basketball that's what my goal is I just
really want to be the best team you can
be something that means so much more
than the best players in position sig
could be in down 10 and 15 and having a
climb back I'll try and do too much but
just trying to play my game oh we got
some tape now and we'll go to the
drawing board and we'll come back and be
much better we try not pay attention to
the noise because you're being in before
I know how to bounce back cuz I know I
play hard it's gonna come back around
I think we're seeing a 14 who in the
next couple of weeks
we'll start in things going and that's
dangerous the does hubs you got to give
it to him but will they recognize it
guys huh keep you at the ball you can't
worry about what happened the past but
you got to forget about all that
and it's time to you know take care of
business they're not done there's some
The Breakers we have to lose he's like
I'm breaking next now may the best to
let's keep talking loose left
[Applause]
and it's so easy look to future at all
we got 82 games to play now you got to
enjoy every night these people pay their
hard-earned money comes in the morning
shooting defined their dynasty in really
this erika festival
[Applause]
to Senator Lee
by starting at 10 for 10 from 3
when you got the hot hand here just
looking for that little bowl
- space all you need to eat your - it
everything's just flicking off through
it so easy you get more comfortable in
your own skin as the years go on I don't
think this is steps T melting in CKD
steam pumping mr. dream loss team my
team but I think this is our team Kevin
Durant Stefan Curry klay Thompson
they've been through these wars they did
through the playoffs for us is not about
relaxing it's about never being
satisfied so your voice Larry O'Brien
what are you gonna leave the NBA what
mark are you gonna leave on the NBA are
you gonna be one of the many run engine
that just go away or you can be one of
those guys like there's econ nicknames
these guys names you see splash brothers
25 years smell OH
curry top you shoot the lights out we're
putting our bodies on the line every
game that's just the nature of our
business
knock on what I've been very blessed
with not very many traumatic injuries of
my career we are really wanna I believe
only greatest teams of to ever play
klay Thompson underrated oftentimes we
do underrate everything how he's able to
take the pressure off stuff curry that's
the trick of the playoffs you know you
feel good tonight
a switch can flip quickly I mean
injuries are never fun it tests your
character
I'll feel much better tomorrow playing
through pain makes it all worth in the
end
okay awkward we owe our fans one more
game and Oracle
[Music]
[Applause]
types of grants
why they get paid Steph Curry slamming
the ball the courts so upset
for me personally you'd be hard to see
me not playing I really want to be out
there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and I was not missing the NBA files from
nothing we work too hard to get to this
point now even if I had a broken leg I
was gonna play the game if they were to
let them stay out there he would stay
that's just who he is
Thompson did not want to come out to
have this happen to him it's just
heartbreaking it just truly tears at
your heart the Golden State Warriors
select klay Thompson from Washington
State University
think I can bring the warriors this
season even though those injuries happen
what they will always be able to look
back on this team those players truly
left their mark on the game you start
with Marty Jackson Justin stealing so
much confidence in us call us the
greatest shooting back for all time
I always tell clay appreciate the game
this is a privilege to play in the NBA
don't take it for granted your worst day
of basketball is will be better than the
best day and basketballs only when you
have 40 years old you say medals a good
days even the bad days I miss first
color you're so dear to prove yourself
my first two years in league I just
wanted to be so great all the time when
you look back on what this team has done
in the mark that they've left them a
sport and then the game that's the thing
that they're gonna remember and be the
most proud it's just fun to have a guy
that's in your shoe barrier so I've
never been in that situation my wife's
like off the Warriors it just motivates
me to
those guys edge their names in the
I made a name for my chefs in this
league
klay Thompson has some ridiculous
accolades to go along with his talent
it goes by so fast players at top 5
funniest teammate that I've ever had oh
snap
yeah Klages boomer himself is a
three-time champion already don't
[Music]
the a-team everyone had to make
on his team and now you're starting to
see plays sacrifice
when you go to five straight I mean it
takes more than just a couple hours yeah
I rather want a championship to be
thirty long
both sigh both
it's great both both of them are great
and we got
[Applause]
I think they just he wanted to get the
locker will be freezing a partner I'll
stay here Clay's my guy we all want to
be play in the next life cool to life no
worries and you know you need to shoot
them anyway you know as a guy who's been
with play for seven years I don't know
many people with a much hardest clay I
could imagine myself being somewhere
else
everybody thinks just kind of end us
we're not done yet